the five craziest best
fantastic beautiful stunning
moves of the lightning kid
sounds like a western but we're talking
about the great vishiwan
anand of india one of the most talented
players
ever to have graced the game of chess
and he's achieved a lot
in his lifetime five times world
champion
and he also had a bit of a surge later
on in his life and he's still playing
great chess as most world champions do
to this day remember to like this video
subscribe to the chess.com channel and
we're going to dive in
to his five best moves in a second
please leave comments after letting me
know what moves
you like you may have seen this first
example before this was
an end with the white pieces against
joel luttier
i may have even used it myself but i had
to include it because
it is stunning and and with the white
pieces
now uses a combination which is
called the windmill what did he now
unleash
on lutier a move which is sparkling
in its execution
bishop to g6
what a shocking move leaving the queen
on pre
and putting the bishop under attack from
not one but two pawns
is that an crazy no he's not his idea
is that if his queen is now captured
with queen takes d1
all of the remaining pieces dive into
the attack and create checkmate can you
see how
rook takes e6 check
using the pin on the s7 pawn the king
has to move
and now this little guy on c1
joins the fun bishop takes h6 check
the king goes into a little bit of a box
there
and there's checkmate in one move bishop
takes f7
a beautiful idea so lucia tried
another defense and he went knight to e7
at least blocking the rook's diagonal
but now anand finished in very clinical
fashion with queen takes d4
rook takes d4 and very cleverly
rook to d3 what he's trying to do here
is swap off a lot of pieces
and keep this bishop on g2 in a trapped
structure
so we can win it later on and after rook
to d8 he simply swapped off rooks when
bishop d3
with a clearly winning position that
little guy there is going nowhere
and white also has the idea of bringing
the dark square bishop into f6
that's surely one of his most beautiful
examples example number two
is anand against bologna a very strong
player
i have to say i've used two of boligan's
losses in these five most amazing moves
sorry bolligan
but they were beautiful now anand's
one of the most dangerous attackers ever
he often didn't sacrifice as such
playing unsoundly but he built up his
attacks
in very methodical and safe ways and
sacrifice when he sacrificed
it generally worked extremely well as
we're gonna see here
after the move c3 what did he now play
clearly the black king has a lot of
pieces hanging around it
and those pieces now need to make their
way through can you see the move
knight to f6 and this is
forcing opening opening up the black
king for example if that knight is taken
we actually take with a g
pawn and now we're threatening queen g5
and either
into g8 or g7
if now h6 trying to stop the queen
getting there a very
nice move king to h1 just preparing
rook g1 rook g8 and checkmate will
follow so after knight to f6
rook to e5 was tried by bolligan trying
to defend and now the second
sparkling moment of this attack g6 and
this may even be a better move than
original knight to f6
opening up the black king in a
devastating way
really nice stuff the point being if
black takes for the h pawn queen h4
forces rook h5 and anand can simply
remove that one
with a winning position and after f
takes g6
the f file is now open and one more
beautiful hit
knight d7 allowing this queen in
bishop to e7 the knight takes the rook
and the queen
sneaks its way into black's position h6
queen e8 and it's going to be checkmate
very soon
or serious loss of material so beautiful
stuff there by aland and you did not
want to be defending against such an
attack
from this great player anand versus
sotloff and
anand was probably most famous for
dismantling the sicilian if you want to
learn how to play the open sicilian with
the white pieces
look at anand's games he is quite
possibly the best ever player on the
white side of the open sicilian
he demolished so many strong players
ivan sotloff
his victim here how did white now
start forcing his way through to get to
that black king
rook takes f7 the first blow
this pulls out the black king and allows
white's queen to
come in via h5 the issue black has here
is his rook is often under attack
so he has to keep defending that one
with king to f8
g6 would lead to checkmate with the
bishop
finally coming in here and after king to
f8 anand now brings his other rook over
this has to be blocked knight to f6 and
removes that guy and after bishop takes
f6
we see again another another follow-up
tactic this is
very typical of anand's play it be one
punch
after another punch he was a combo chest
puncher
knight on d to b5 unleashing the bishop
to the to the knight here the other side
of the ball criss-crossing
towards the black king sokolov took that
one
knight takes tempo on the queen queen d7
and now simply queen takes h7 creating a
deadly fret can you see the fret
remember you can pause if you want to
look a little bit deeper this move
again is quite magical because you could
have taken a knight with check
but there's an even stronger fret for
example have b6 being played the fret is
rook takes f6 followed by bishop h6
and mate sokolov tried
queen to e7 but we see now rook f6
anyway the pawn cannot capture and after
queen takes
bishop takes c5 rookie 7 queen h8
knight is gonna come into d6
and sotloff resigned in a hopeless
position the black king
cannot do anything another piece will
dive in very
very nice stuff from that when looking
at anand's best moves it's very hard
just to pick one move
because like i said he's a combo puncher
and this is one of his most famous games
poor old bolligan again
bologna whenever he gets paired against
anand must shed a little tear of pain
and after bishop b7 from bologna and and
again
creates a piece of art rook takes
e6 and this just rips open
the black king this rook has to be taken
and here comes the second punch look for
the forcing moves
bishop to e7 check beautiful stuff
drawing the king away from g7 the queen
dives in there
if the black king now goes to the back
rank let's say here
queen takes h8 will be deadly so the
king comes forwards
and now just simply knight takes d4
even though anand is a whole rook down
the black king is
completely exposed to all of white's
pieces
in this position and after queen to c5
and ant now played another beautiful
move
beauty after beauty bishop to f5
i would love to play a game like this
this gets ready to
move that night with a deadly check for
example if that bishop is taken
we can go knight to b5 check and the
knight will drop
next move for example this is just one
checkmate
that could have occurred really nice
stuff and after bishop f5 the knight's
now ready
to move black tries queen to e5
but knight to f3 is going to win the
black queen
and win the game again typical anand
energy you can see why you also gained
the name of tiger
with his energetic and brilliant attacks
well it's white to play and win and his
opponent is ninof
and this came from one of his books on
his most amazing
games now the next move we see
often in attacking combinations but it
does
have a unique follow-up here hence why i
picked it can you see the move
bishop takes h7 but more importantly
it's not just the move that you have to
see it's the follow-up a very good bit
of advice actually is
a lot of russian and good trainers when
they give
tests to their pupils they don't say
what's the first move
they say what's the last move in the
combination
you you might see the first move but you
could just be losing a piece here
unless you see what to do next and what
is the point here
did you see this when you were looking
g6
and i loved this move if the pawn
captures
we win the rook win the game and if the
king captures
on g6 then queen d3 and this king
is gonna have nowhere to run to one very
nice line goes
king h6 knight to f5 check giving up
another
piece but taking the f5 square away and
after queen h3
and rook g1 we can see that black is
helpless beautiful
beautiful move so g6 check
force king g8 and now queen h3
threatening checkmate on h7
combination punching knight to f6 was
tried
if pawn takes g6 the rook would have
captured on f8
and then simply knight to e6 check and
black's rook drops and he's under attack
after knight to f6 simply pawn takes f6
and black resigned after pawn takes g6
pawn takes g7
the black king has been completely
ripped apart very very nice stuff from
anand
you can see his pure talent here which
of those moves was your favorite
do remember to like and subscribe to the
chess.com channel
also please suggest whatever plays you'd
like me to
continue analyzing in this series hope
you enjoyed that
goodbye for now